[Music]
when it comes to keeping it friendly
with x's Ben Affleck and Jennifer Garner
are doing it right we're gonna do our
best check out Ben's big grin as he
chats it up with Jen's longtime bow
businessman John Miller the Meetup went
down on Monday after Jen and John parked
their car outside Jen's house and they
walked hand in hand to catch up with Ben
the guy shook hands and spoke for
several minutes before Jen joined them
and the group went inside Ben's ear to
ear smile really says it all the family
doesn't have to look like any particular
model you what it needs is like love
adults that care about you the happy
exchange comes just a week after another
blended family moment this time
involving Ben's other half Jennifer
Lopez we're super happy
um what can I tell you we're just having
a good time yeah the afflecks joined Jen
Garner at their kids serafina's school
for a musical performance J.Lo even
brought her 14 year old Emmy Affleck and
Garner were married from 2005 to 2018
and shared three children Violet
seraphim and Samuel I have kids and
they're funny and smart and you know I
think they're awesome as for the dynamic
between the families the source told E.T
in November Jen and Jen Garner have a
lot of respect for each other
meanwhile benifer has been making the
most of married life in July the pair
tied the knot in an intimate Sin City
ceremony we were planning to get married
you know in August in Savannah that was
like okay the family's gonna be there
everybody's going to be there and it was
so stressful and a month before and I
don't know if you guys know this but 20
years ago we were supposed to get
married we were so happy and of course
it was happening but I just felt like
the wedding was so stressful and one day
Ben just says
okay let's just go to Vegas and get
married tonight and just a month later
they did it up really big in Georgia and
had a true fairy tale wedding surrounded
by family and friends it was honestly
one of the like 10 sweetest uh precious
most precious moments I've ever
witnessed in my life it was absolutely
beautiful it was truly special it was
beautiful to celebrate love and when ET
spoke to JLo earlier this month safe to
say married life has her on cloud nine
what's the best part of this chapter and
and you know being married to Ben
there's so many things I mean I I
couldn't I you don't have enough time
right now
he's a beautiful man he's dreaming
[Music]